this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 8th
the joint is sponsored by and we want to
welcome to the podcast factor listen if
you can't stand the heat stay the [__]
out of the kitchen fact is here to give
you delicious healthy meals that are
ready in minutes
with fact that you spend less time in
the kitchen which gives you a lot more
fun in the sun factors fresh never
frozen prepared meals are tremendous you
wouldn't believe they're actually good
for you they offer 30 meals each week
and you'll never be bored with the meal
plans each meal arrives prepared and
ready to eat in two minutes
that's faster than ordering a pizza and
they come pre-prepared
i'm gonna tell you what they sent this
week they got a keto me
monterey chicken they got a poblano ball
they got a jalapeno papa burger they got
a smothered pork chop and a garlic
braised beef that's just one of the many
they got vegan and veggie meals low
calorie options cold proof cold pressed
juices smoothies which are tremendous
energy bites and plant-based bars and
extra protein and veggie sides
that sounds tremendous to me so do me a
favor just head over go to
go.facto75.com
again
that's go.facto75.com
joey120 and i'm gonna get you a hundred
and twenty dollars off your first order
that's codejoey120
at gold.factor75.com
slash joey120 for 120 off your first
order healthy eating is made easy and
this makes it real easy for you i had
one of the shrimp dishes the other night
the first time i got it and i'll tell
you what
you know that we've had a lot of food
this
is delicious tremendous and even my wife
couldn't believe how easy it is so take
a look just take a look go.factor75.com
[Music]
if you like something
listen joey120 and i'm gonna get you 120
off the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion in a world that is [__]
flooded with a bunch of [__] bad cbd
i'm coming at you with good cbd whether
it's the gummies whether it's the bath
balls the kinesiology tape the patches
that you can just put on your shoulder
or you need
cbd capsules also they got [__]
got delta eight they got those gummies
with the cbd in them that you'll [__]
see the devil listen i'm gonna give you
20 off your first order when you put in
joint
joey or church that's how we work at 20
off to have the best cbd you've been
hearing all about it now it's your time
to attack
cbdline.com read the third party lab
results
learn and when you get what you want
pressing code joey and get 20 off and
then hit me with a twitter and say joey
that's the best cbd i've used cbd lion
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings listen the card is [__]
stacked this week you got joanna against
the chinese girl you got [__] uh
valentina you got glover talks listen
knockout submission what flying kicks
it's all over new customers i'll tell
you what i'm gonna do bet five hours on
any ufc 275 fight and get 150 and free
bets instantly when you [__] collect
you're looking for an even bigger payday
uncle joey got it for you with draftking
sportsbook newest feature same game
parlays
the more legs the more guidance you
[__] win it's that easy place the
same game paulie for saturday nights ufc
and if it hits you double your earning
not to mention i got nba playoffs not to
mention i got baseball on full [__]
swing it's still early so you could
still [__] clip or win here download
the draftking sportsbook app today use
promo code joey throw down a nickel five
hours to win
150 in free bets instantly it'll keep
you playing three nba playoffs
baseball and more ufc bellator
they got it all on [__] draftkings
that's code joey this saturday at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc
download the sports book app now i love
you [__] let's get this party
started we got lisa dropping some
knowledge here today
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 8th of june welcome
to the joint
it's been a great [__] week so far
i'm feeling good i had a little blast of
[__] diarrhea the other night in the
middle of the night it was a nightmare i
went to fart and it came out the juice i
had to run out of bed
i'm sorry to open up the podcast with
this but sometimes you just got to be
[__] honest it's a beautiful day to
be alive man uh
a lot is going on but then again
nothing's going on i could lie to you
ain't the [__] going on i'm just getting
ready for the [__] summer see what
we're gonna do with the birthday
see if i get on stage one night this
week to keep working this
but uh today we're gonna talk about i
want to talk to you guys about something
you know i didn't know where i was going
to go with uh ozzie's boneyard when i
moved here ozzy's boneyard had me
do a couple uh aussies devil sets or
whatever the [__] they call them and it
was great and they still talk to me and
stuff like that but
what happened at sirius was they took
their money and they gave it to guys
like morello and guys like um
you know the bass player duff from
uh
guns and roses and you know
i mean for for me i could do sessions on
there and i'll they send you a check a
little check
nothing to get rich on you know nothing
like that it's just a check right and i
love doing it but it didn't seem like it
was going to go anywhere like i said i'm
still friendly with those guys they
still send me stuff and invite me to
stuff i just
it's the way things go i'm not mad at
serious i'm not mad at the heavy metal
any of that [__] i just you know i
support i love them but you know
you i've never
since you've been watching the church
and all this [__] i've never told you to
stop giving up you know we don't give up
here on the church
so i've been scratching my head on the
patreon i do like the album of the week
and it's it's it is what it is but
lee sent me an email a few weeks ago
about this app called amp and if you
guys could do me the biggest favor
and download the app it won't cost you a
[__] dime
it's a little yellow
app it's uh i think it's part they
they're owned by amazon
and what that does is i could be of my
own little [__] dj at night
you set up a set list of how many songs
you want to play you know and uh
you just go live on the [__] computer
on the internet all you need is uh
is the amp uh app and so please
download your amp app and send it in and
then in a few days i'll send you an
email it's not going to cost you a dime
i wouldn't ask you to do something if it
was gonna cost you money i'm not one of
those [__] clowns
and let's experiment with this you know
mike's into music you know i'm into
music
uh lee as he's the guest today he'll
tell you that he wants to do a comedy
one because they have comedy on there
it's a great [__] uh app and
if we get it going like maybe i don't
know
wednesdays at nine o'clock at night that
means la at three you know like a late
night to la at six i'm sorry
i like to do something like that so
download the app what i'm gonna do is
find a night that i'm home
that i could just sit back here with you
[__] and just play [__]
music not the same music we've been
playing these guys got everything i
thought that they would have like a
limited amount like
this band doesn't want to do it but i
guess everybody's on amazon pays for
your [__] whatever
and you uh
do your own [__] radio show and
that's what we're about guys we create
our own things i mean now these apps are
making it that
you don't you need less and less
you have no excuses all you need is a
[__] computer your computer has a mic
on it right the
the [__] pads that i have have the
mic on them just like your [__] phone
you're talking to the mic and i listen
man i tape my [__] patreon messages
on my phone
we tape with the [__] with the
[__] phone i mean you know there's so
many things you could do with the phone
listen it's not going to be studio
[__] quality but then again when
there's any you know you know what i'm
saying that's what you signed up for
because it's pirate [__] radio yes or
no so let's download the amp app do
uncle joey a big favor download the app
please not gonna cost you nothing you
know hit me on twitter or on patreon let
me know you got it and [__] uh
i'll start doing i'll put together a
little radio show at night for us you
know just
on uncle joey playlist i don't give a
[__] i'll do a spot le uh spotify play
i'll do whatever [__] you guys uh
want to talk about you know there i'll
take suggestions and [__] we'll do some
different things i don't think i could
take calls and stuff like that i don't
think i'd go around playing eddie trunk
but it would be a good [__] time so
do me a favor download the amp app now
do uncle joey a favor leah favor mike of
favor we're gonna get on this [__]
thing and that's it no more cans with a
string in between we've come a long
[__] way [__]
i'm feeling good i'm gonna do go do some
comedy thursday night this week
to work out friday i got a softball
tournament inside i got a softball tone
i think if she wins she plays sunday
it's a [__] all weekend type thing
but hey that's what that's what i signed
up for
beside that man i got leon today we uh i
got to get leon once a month
just to break it down for you
[__] to see today we talk about
stand-up
you know the funnest stand up and
just me and lee
i love you [__] enjoy the
podcast and i'll see you guys next week
there's no outro i'm just going to outro
right from the zoom video why [__]
around with you [__] i love your
stay black and don't forget
dna comes out on
june 18th at the ice cream shop i just
gave mike a chunk of it to try to
stuck it in the thanksgiving turkey it's
scary to look at it's brown and gray and
it's got orange hairs
and uh we got tremendous coming out july
26th at the ice cream shop all products
of ziki
and let's narrow it down the
[__] the laughing gas division
with uncle joey we gave a ton away away
last weekend atlantic city hopefully you
[__] like it and uh when we come to
jersey
you'll be buying it at the store that's
all i can tell you right now stay black
i love you have a great week and enjoy
lisayet on the joint zoom today
[Music]
what's happening brother hey buddy it's
a beautiful [__] wednesday
the joez show who gives a [__] what's up
tarzan
you're looking more more like the dude
from [__] uh
what's that dude's name
the guy from uh my name is earl that
lost all the weight with the beard
he's going to look like him all he needs
two big [__] muscles over here and
it's all over but the shot even simply i
look more like him before he lost the
weight than now but he god he's so
ripped i don't know how he does it he
just went off balls and started lifting
weights and throwing houses around
and you just get [__] ripped after a
while i don't know how people do it
anymore what's happening brother
i'm doing great man i'm very i'm just
happy it's been it's been a good couple
weeks
i feel like i was just out to see you
that was a blast
i don't know what's good
life is happening what's happening with
you ah we just finished up that [__]
uh
atlantic city yeah
and uh
you know lee it was fun
it wasn't me on stage like it was just
rough getting into myself i just got off
the phone with ari and i was telling ari
that
i figured out what's wrong
you know when you i haven't been having
fun
like i like going out for me to just get
in the car and go do comedy for 10
minutes
gets my dick card for right now that's
what gets my dick card for right now
but
at the same time when i go to these
places like i try to go to these but i
don't even want to announce it no more
you know i try to either go to like uh
new brunswick distress factory or i go
to my mandinos or vinnie brands great
too over at new brunswick great club
great food around there [__] vinnie
dinos is great vinnie's uh
uncle vinnie's comedy club they got like
a lobster shack next door to it oh they
got a chinese joint next to it they got
the whole block is you know point
pleasant's got great food
plus you got a [__] livoli's down i
think i think you got a little bodies
down there but anyway
so you know these clubs are not the
comedy store and that's okay i don't
care
so when you go to them it's like you
know during the week it's not like you
know you're getting a massage in the
back sam's giving you a massage in the
back and [__]
they're giving out free weed it's it's a
regular show like i started that at
westminster at uh which said the comedy
club right three guys
everybody goes home nobody hangs at the
bar you know it's just a comedy club you
know so
i've been just trying to go down there
and get on stage but the problem is that
i want to have fun now now it's time to
have fun open mike and for me right now
i want to go through that whole open mic
process i went
from 93 to 95 which is just show up
right show up right show up i can't do
it every night like tonight i got a
softball game tomorrow night i got
something else what
friday she's got a softball game
saturday she's got a softball game you
know i'll try to get out thursday night
this week
but i haven't been having fun yet
it's hard it's a big part of it i have i
went through a very small version of
that but i had such good friends that i
did open mics with in la that when i
came back
to bar or i came to boston
it was just a very different experience
it was an hour away i didn't know
anybody it was instead of it was four
hours of waiting
and it just i the last open mic i did
here i hosted for four hours
and
not a single person got a laugh the
entire four hours
and i including myself i'm including
myself and i i had to go up and down
steps every three minutes and my legs
hurt at the end of the night
and i just i was sitting there i was
like what am i doing
and the sad part is i do miss it but
it's just
i didn't
i'm a very anti-social per and not even
anti-social i'm just shy
i don't like talking i'm not good at
going to a group of people that i don't
really know
and like it takes me a few times of
seeing you to be like okay i can talk
with this person and it just
it was hard for me
to get into the groove but i feel sim i
miss it a lot and i didn't do it for as
long as you did it or successfully so i
can't imagine how you feel
for young comics
it's very hard to say this
but i'll tell you a story to follow and
it doesn't concern it doesn't involve me
it was ari
when ari first was starting out you know
he was doing comedy i don't know five
six years
not making any money you know hanging
out at the store he wasn't really a
regular he says that one night ralphie
said to him i don't know you've been
doing comedy
and whatever and ari replied to him and
i already said and he goes oh my god
that's the best
best time of doing comedy and ralphie
you know ari goes what being broke
and he goes you don't it's not that the
fun you have at those open the reason
why you're broke
is because you're having fun
right and you don't really give a [__]
you're part of a clique that mike's
broke i'm broke you're broke everybody's
[__] broke okay like i said nobody
drives an open mic on a lamborghini so
everybody's broke so after a couple
months we get to realize that we're a
fearsome threesome
okay one for all and one for whatever
that [__] thing all for one and one
for all yeah so now it's like me josh
wolf gavin and uh brody
you know how much you got i got four i
got ten i got eleven okay we'd get
nachos we could do this
or we could hold off and just get a
thing of nachos and split em three ways
and then we go to mccormick and schmitz
for the happy hour i don't know if i can
make mission schmidt i need a hamburger
right now
but the hamburger later is gonna be two
bucks
right at ten you know so
and but now let's live let's get away
from that
you look at that and you're like joey
what's so fun about that
when you look back at that
you go oh my god
what would you rather do
do what us three just discussed we're
doing uh split of cheeseburgers and
nachos or
we got to get on the [__] conference
call because they want me lee and
[__] mike want to work together
and mike's agent won't allow it because
you know mike wants to do it he's
already told his agent he wants to do it
but we have to have a conference call
because mike feels that [__] since he
just came out in the movie he should get
40 and me and lisa get 30 of the commit
and and we that's not fun
that is not [__] fun when your agent
calls you and says what do you want to
charge
35 or 55 dollars if you charge 50 and
you're like
i just want to have fun well that's
that's
give me a number that'll that could pay
my rent
cocaine the hooker
you know that's what you want just give
me give me the budget what's it cost to
be with a hooker for two days and stab
her at the end what's the pimp want and
clean up the room dispose the body i
want to do coca and it's going to cost
you eight dollars just give me you know
what i'm saying like i just want what i
need i don't want nothing above i don't
need to drive a nice car
i could have lived that way foreverly
because
you're doing what the [__] you want
right so you're taking twenty dollars
less but you don't gotta deal with
anybody
right i mean you're not gonna put on a
shirt and a dress you don't gotta
[__] go to a sales meeting
so
this is these are the things that are
fun sometimes being broke
is a lot more fun than just having money
i'll take your word for it
you know let me put to this way guys
okay right now
we're doing our thing alison change is
playing with [__] i'll give you an
example and the people at home
understand this michael understand this
a little bit better than julia allison
change is playing with bush
october 7th at the [__]
at the pnc okay
if we have money
we just call each other mike what do you
want to do there's tickets on third row
bro for the extra 25 it's 180.
who gives a [__] just buy the ticket
joey all right we buy the tickets 180 a
piece
three [__] tickets to go see two
bands
180 is way overpriced but that's what
the deal is today
and then i call we're not going to drive
we're getting [__] up we're taking
edibles
i got to get a limo
take an uberx go [__] yourself
jack
so you know and but before that we're
going to get a nice dinner we're getting
a nice 300 then a couple steaks we're
going to go in there and guess what guys
at the end of the night we're just going
to walk into the concert
whatever's going to be great on the
guitar alison chain's going to be great
bush and we go home
let me rewrite that story for you right
now mike calls me dog bush is playing
tonight did you know no i didn't
do you want to go how much of the
tickets mike 28 okay i got like 22. let
me see if i can borrow 20. call lee
leave
tell lee about alice and change see if
joey could borrow 20 yeah he'll give you
the 20. what is that 20 going to do for
us
we're going to get
three joints
you know we're going to go down that
dinner that we talked about at the
restaurant forget it
he had a peanut butter and jelly from
his kid i took [__] mercy sandwich
and you i don't know you took your
mother's bingo sandwich we [__] eat
and then
we go to this concert but when we get in
this concert we we're up in the back and
all of a sudden mike sees his friend
from the open mic and he waves us over
and we're down in third row and all of a
sudden joints are passing around there's
a chick who keeps
smoking pot and drinking and the more
more she falls asleep and by the third
song she's [__] passed out in the
thing and every 20 minutes you check on
and go that [__] is dead and you keep
going down in a hole and all of a sudden
somebody gives you a hit acid he knows
what i'm talking about the chick that's
hammered at the beginning i love it and
she's bouncing the ball and [__] and
once the concert starts that [__] is
done she's passed out
everybody's watching her some guys are
looking her finger but some dudes are
saying what should we do with this chick
she's just passed out [__] it that's
what you get for drinking at two in the
afternoon
and then we laugh at that then the
[__] mike's friend says come with us
and we walk down philadelphia street we
go get a hot dog we didn't have any
money
but the guy my friend said give joey in
and all of a sudden we went to a concert
for 18 a piece
we ate three hot dogs we we did acid we
did all these things on the last minute
right it's how comedy is sometimes
yep and even even with that concert
because i just went through this
you let's say you put all that money
into it there's a lot more at stake
you're expecting a lot more from the
concert you could have both of you could
have been down in front of one in the
bleachers but because the you only spent
20 bucks you don't care that they didn't
play this song or that the sound wasn't
great when you're spending a grand
a night to go to see this you're like
this better be [__] good
it's there's a lot more at stake and
that's why even with me you're saying
with the comedy oh i just need what i
what i like to live
i was paying to do open mics
i i was happy when i did a set that i
got 20 bucks and a drink ticket like
that was a good night for me but that's
got to stop
event i mean i was only two years in
season i was early that works in la in
new york listen i don't mind bringing 10
people
you know
when mike plays his guitar he does his
open mic he's got to bring four people
so we all go support him he comes to us
he brings his brother whatever
that i don't mind i never got pissed off
at that
i got pissed off at
taking
money from comics that's something that
has always bothered me
you know any artist musician
painter
you know whatever comic
i don't like when they get abused those
first five years because it leaves a
taste
in your mouth i hope you don't get
abused but because people are scumbags
they do
try to take advantage you come do this
gig and often they put five dollars in
your hand with two drink tickets and
you're like [__] i drove an hour and a
half but that's
you got to pay your dues in the
beginning you know but that's right
i didn't want comics to pay five bucks
to get on stage you know what i never
did
was right
i don't even know if anybody charged
that i'm trying to think it was because
i was cheap at the time or whatever but
i
i only remember having to bring people
in new york like when i came to new york
in 93 i had to bring people the comics
career people that
stand up new york and all that [__] and
then you go to colorado and there's no
such just come to the
book or say just come
it's a bar show you know i don't expect
nothing you know what i'm saying so
i don't know i don't like that i didn't
like that in l.a but in l.a i didn't
like
i didn't like open mic and
i was very against it because it made
you it put more pressure on you it took
the fun away
they took the fun away because there's
always that one kid that comes in yeah i
think i'm gonna sign with gersh this
ain't a virgin party
this ain't a gersh type and now in
seattle when i was an open mic nobody
talked
an agent you just had a club in a
basement on a monday and tuesday what
are you [__] talking about cbs
what are you talking about right and i i
get that i just got very lucky with a
few people um in la i definitely saw a
lot of that and a lot of people would
come in
that
had delusions of grander which i'm sure
is everywhere now
but
but i um
it's it's just different it's you're
following a dream even though
it's not going to happen for 99.5 of the
people doing it
and it's just
like this is this working this job which
i actually really like for the past six
months has shown me i have a i have a
lot more respect for a lot of my friends
that were doing the open mics because a
lot of my days were free there were days
that we had to do stuff but i had a lot
more time than they did
and
to see the difference between
a job and then following a dream
there's a big difference there's a big
difference and it's um
and but and stand-up is fun like that's
i love i i watch stand up almost every
day i love going to shows i have more
fun doing stand up than i had than i do
watching stand up
making those people laugh like that
at my level was some of the most fun
i've ever had
it's just exciting just me especially me
you know me i'm a shy i don't like being
the center of attention but something
about being on stage
when it's working it it's just
it might even be better than sex at some
points i think even when it's not
working
i don't like that just [__] being
listen it's an uncomfortable feeling
it's an uncomfortable feeling as [__]
but
god
what else
makes you that [__] uncomfortable
coming in two minutes
yeah using a hot chick and going i'm
gonna [__] your brains and then taking
her upstairs and giving her 30 second
squeeze and what happened i don't know
you know
this
there's so many [__] things that
like i for me
you know i was a drug addict at the time
my dick got hard when i opened up a
[__] box and i saw a kilo a coke or
a bundle of 20s you know that was what
got me out before stand-up was stealing
and doing all that stupidity
walking on that i there's a lot of
things in my life i don't remember like
i remember but you can't really
i remember the day but i don't remember
the feeling
i can't remember the feeling i had when
i saw them throw dirt on my mother's
casket for the first time and you turn
around
it's a horrible feeling i remember
the feeling of
getting off that stage that night i will
never forget that feeling
you know why
because i will never get a drug
that strong
to make me feel that way
there isn't a drug in the earth
to describe to you
how a person feels
when they got on stage for the first
time and they just but listen
the feeling of
of euphoria that you get anytime you
don't think you're gonna do something
and you do
the time you looked at that girl and
says i'll never get her girl and all of
a sudden you're with and you're sucking
the titties and you're coming on the
stomach and you're like
i gotta go back to my house and think
about what just happened you know
all these things when mike first got in
the band and he played a song up on
stage and they're walking off what's the
feeling mike
you can't a [__] ain't coming close
to that feeling when people are clapping
nothing comes close to the high
from making
people feel good and then it goes back
to
making somebody's day every day
yeah stand up is branched off that
you have to want to make somebody's day
every day you're not gonna [__] kill
that audience when you do a show whether
it's a thousand people
or forty people there's one person in
that audience
you're gonna really get to and as you
expand the numbers it's more when guns
and roses does a 20 000 seat arena
they're entertaining 20 000 people
but they're getting to
a percentage of that
18 people who
got that euphoric they haven't seen them
before they
whatever they've never been to a live
concert before you know
anything alive will always rock your
[__] world baseball games a play
yeah you know anything live
well and i i
i still don't really understand what
like what we did with the church i
really don't i
i do but i don't really get it but i was
driving the other day and i wasn't
having a good day i was listening to a
podcast
and for a second
i was laughing and i didn't expect to
laugh and i was just it took me away
from having a a
i wasn't that shitty but you know i was
i wasn't in the right space mine and i i
was driving i was like [__]
i finally understood some of those
emails or things when people say oh
i've been listening to you for 10 years
i appreciate it but it doesn't really
make sense to me but
with the same i think it's the same
thing with podcasting is that
for some
some for even like a second people will
forget oh [__] i i'm late on the rent or
my boss is a dick or whatever i think i
think all this stuff
is great for that
it does
it does you guys
it's uh
like someone i was i was on i was taking
i took a walk yesterday and and one of
the guys was saying his favorite part of
the church where were the was the
openings with the music and you
screaming and throwing [__] at me and
dancing like one of the best openings
was tutorial and um
the actor rapaport rapaport you got all
all four of us just dancing opening that
was
those openings man were
just fun even for those 30 seconds was
more fun than i've had in two years like
those it was just fun
you know man uh
those are some [__]
again nobody knew listen i knew what i
was doing when i was doing stand-up i
want people to understand this i knew
what i was doing
from the minute i got on stage i knew
what i was doing then you get more hip
to it and then you learn the process and
but you know what you're doing
at least you know where you're going you
know when you join a band
we're gonna play [__] pearl jam songs
i know where i'm [__] going there's
been a thousand million bands before me
there's been a thousand comics before me
with podcasting
i did not know where we were going do
you understand me so it didn't matter to
me whether i wanted to throw spaghetti
on the wall or to light your nutsack on
fire then
remember the podcast game has changed
dramatically in 10 years now yep you get
flagged with jesus christ who fought it
that cat just blew a trip it wasn't me
can't blame me uh
so now it's a different game with the
podcast now people have a beginning a
middle of ending
you can't put music in them
you can't and i'm you're sitting here
going okay you know you can't if you
take an album and put it on in the
background and [__] show that you get
flagged by copyright if you say the
wrong thing you come up in your [__]
videos no under 18
it's a different [__] world today so
you know again
but we could still push the envelope
from time to time you can still push it
i mean you know who gives listen
i just found the clip a couple days ago
somebody made like a little clip
and i was saying some wild [__]
i was saying some wild [__] i'm like wow
that hasn't gotten flagged and that
hasn't gotten me canceled yet or
anything that's an old you know but
nobody knew what we were doing yeah and
who gave a [__] we made and broke the
rules while we were doing it
yeah
and we set the bar where we wanted to
you know people doing mushrooms going to
do a set people passing out
people's changing lives you know my
neighbor this nice lady she sells real
estate in town
her and her husband are a real estate
team they're sweethearts they don't
curse they got two kids and one of their
daughter plays with my daughter
so we saw them the night and and she
kept talking to her husband about
something and she goes you know what
my brother used to work for
somebody
in the entities like a producer and she
goes when i told him i was gonna go see
you
he said that you were the dude that
[__] killed bowen benjamin what does
that mean and
i had to tell this nice [__] lady
about an edible
and when i called him he had to be up by
the [__] cheese fake cake factory up
on sepulveda
that's where he was that night for
people who want to know and leo you made
it all the way there
dog he was at my house and he made it to
[__] sepulveda and ventura that's a
[__] hike walking that edible that
that edible gave you energy [__] red
bull because that [__] walked to
sepulveda that night when i called him
that night jesus and he answered the
phone
this is now i can look back at that
story and tell you exactly what happened
when i you ever smoke a joint go for a
walk guys two joints and get really high
and go for a walk it's a beautiful
[__] thing
the first 10 minutes are a little
uncomfortable and then you become a
slave to your mind
and you just walk and think of all these
things and reefer and [__]
and you're getting all and all saying
you bump into the hot dog man it's like
listen before people started getting
stabbed and you had to wear masks and
[__] in new york
you want to [__] you could either go
to a psychiatrist or you could smoke a
joint in the village and start walking i
used to smoke a joint on 178th street
and start walking
start walking i would put on and uh
really gay i'm telling you the time
period this was my favorite albums at
the time were
rat invasion of your privacy 1985 i
would
get off port authority small you know i
was going through hell at that time i
was still [__] mourning my mother i
was doing a thousand [__] things
and i'm i would just [__] smoke the
best weed
biting harlem and walk from 178
dog sometimes i make it to 125.
jesus you know 125th street just to go
to harlem
and take the express train the a train
down because after that you got to take
this train with every stop just dump
things like that you could just walk and
break down your life what's your next
move what's your next
you know that's a that's a form of
meditation that worked for me for years
just smoking go for a walk what are your
phones on that's it and you whatever
problem you got when you begin that walk
when you get back from that walk
that problem will be solved you're like
a [__] detective you're cracking [__]
that's why i like driving now i can't i
can't drive that high but that's why i
like those cross-country drives because
that's what i do
i'm just not high but it's
god i'm sorry oh no it's just it's
there's something about doing anything
where you literally
can't be focused on something else like
even now you could do that now in new
york i don't know about smoking you
could take an edible but
you can't look at your phone because
you'll walk into something
listen if i give you a 200 milligram cbo
abx
i dare you to walk in the city
you'll get stabbly because you
you walk around like a [__] dunce
anybody i give that [__] to i would not
recommend them to go into the city well
you have to give them 200 milligrams you
can give them 500 what's the use you
know i'm saying you can't walk the city
streets of new york with 10 milligrams
don't you think a little too woke-ish
i'm so sorry
the other day
i was uh last week you know
i'm home i'm home it's raining mercy's
got covered
we're stuck and
last week my week got turned around on
thursday night
i ran upstairs got in the shower i was
gonna go meet eleanor atlantic city but
the sky was black
and it's 130 miles to atlanta no it's an
hour and a half to atlantic city so i
didn't want to drive one and a half one
and a half back and then friday morning
have to get back up and drive another
one and a half so i said [__] it i'm
gonna save my back
i'm gonna go down to uncle vinnie's
that drive that night was like a [__]
uh it's like it's like uh a session it
was like a therapy session
because i was a little high i stopped
and i bought a vapor pen it [__]
broke already two vapor plants but they
both [__] broke and i take the
charger out the guts come out with it
what the [__] oh jesus so
i took my little vapor pen i got super
high on some rainbow ruts and i took my
vapor pen and i went i drove to [__]
santa monica oh santa monica point
please you know they're just playing
great [__] music from one song to
another you know i got it from 70s on
seven seven on 70s to 90s to [__]
lithium
to ozzy's boneyard to studio 54 and it
just kept [__] they were throwing
heat
it got to the point where i got the
point pleasant i didn't want to get out
of the car
that's how good the music was i mean
everything they were playing allison
chains they were playing [__] led
zeppelin black sabbath i listened to
jimmy on uh [__] serious and ozzie's
bone yard
that was enough for me
that ride was what i needed and i've
always told my wife i was built on the
ride
when
all those stories i tell those were on
good nights when we went out and snorted
coke
but there was a lot of bad nights too
what do you do on those nights me mike
comes to pick me up
i got rolling papers we pick you up
mike puts two dollars in i put five
dollars in and you put three dollars in
we buy a ten dollar bag
we roll a joint
and then we each split a half a joint
and we go home
so you smoke a joint we stop at the ice
cream man or a bodega get a [__]
carvel ice cream or a cup ice cream we
get in the car we talk so if mike in
those days would pick me up at 8 15
i'd be back in my house by 9 15 9
o'clock
that was enough for me that real little
ride smoking a joint and going to carvel
and coming home
i'm good
the fresh air
we would do that in l.a sometimes you'd
show up at my house i'd sit in your car
and we wouldn't even go anywhere
we talked for a minute you give me an
applause give me usually had some food
for me too and we'd i'd go upstairs and
leave what else is there to say there's
nowhere to go
there's no way to go you were saying
something before that i want to talk
about
before you get out of here i know you
got to go back to work or wherever the
[__] you going
what are we going to do with this amp
[__]
that we got
with this amp [__] app
it's a cool app it seems new it seems
like they're they're starting it out but
it's it's just
i was talking about you at the about the
openings of the church there's something
that you have with music
um
that
is special and it's
it's just the amp seems like the new
evolution
sort of like what podcasting did for
radio but now
they allow you to play music
so and you can you can take calls i
think you can i think you can talk on it
too
um i played around with it a little bit
but when i saw i saw an article about it
and it just seemed perfect for you
i like it i've uh i set up a show
already one night and i got so high i
forgot to do it
i said it show up like three weeks ago
on a monday but i didn't do it right
because everybody needs to get the amp
app right right yeah yeah you have to
have the amp app um i haven't opened it
in a little bit but the last time i
opened it um like you you have to like
follow
joey and or whoever and then you'll get
a notification um but yeah it's all
within the amp app you have access to a
lot of different music i always think i
was looking at it they have comedy i was
thinking about doing a show for comedy
because you can play tracks on there
um
it's just it's just another like and the
best thing for you is you can do it from
right there you could do it from in bed
because i don't think there's any video
i'm almost positive there's not is
you'll just be there you'll have your
little playlist you can i think you can
speak like do like do in between songs
yeah and it's uh
you just get to show people the song and
and like exactly what you're doing on
that drive to point pleasant you could
do for people
and switch between songs and and you
don't have to do commercials you don't
have to worry about
about you know the boss said i can't
play this one anymore because i play
this whenever you could play the same
song on a loop if you wanted to you
could do whatever you wanted
now
the amp app doesn't cost you anything i
don't believe so no when i did it it
didn't when i did it you had to sign up
and they would email you a login code i
think you might have a special link now
if i'm not mistaken if not i'm sure we
can get you one um
that will
maybe let you bypass it but yeah it's
called amp it's like a yellow let me
pull it up it's like a yellowish
um logo
and yeah it looks like this it's a
little a
a yellow and an a
it's cool man it's um
like i said i think it's at the very
beginning but it seems like it has a lot
of cool um
options
dog they got everything on there yeah
like i was really in shock
they had nirvana they got allison chains
they got
black sabbath they got leonard skinnet
they had uh
i just looked up like random people like
uh
the gambler the guy that sang the song
the game with kenny rogers they got him
on there they got dolly parton on there
they got uh run dmc on there they got
biggie i mean they have
you know i sat on there for like 45
minutes one night just trying to trump
them to see because you know how led
zeppelin didn't go on itunes for a long
time you know right there's a lot of
bands that won't i figured you know if
they want they're not going to sign up
for this
right
yeah i think i think this might be
somehow linked to i think amazon might
own it or something i'm not exactly i'm
not exactly sure who owns it um but yeah
they have
it's not just a couple of you know
no-name artists that you've never heard
of it's it's people that you want to
hear i did not even think
to check the comedy genre
i did not even think to check the comedy
they have they have stuff they they have
a lot of stuff um
it's just it's cool it feels like uh it
feels like the beginning of podcasting
it's just it's it's new it's like it's
like moving around
and and it like the app was it was like
brand new
people were figuring out how to use it
what's that
it was what we did the first like 100
episodes of the that's why there's no
video of the church because one day
sticking was like bye
they just weren't there anymore
and then we switched to ustream so it's
uh
it was just it's it it just is cool it's
it's allowing people
a different way to connect
and and i mean you know more than anyone
how people feel about music and and i
mean i've been on i've been with you on
that ride a thousand times where you're
switching between the stations and you
love something you turn it up it's um
i mean people ask for your playlist all
the time you you have a great playlist
and and you and the and the thing with
you is you get excited about it you're
not just sitting there like with your
hand on your chest like listening you
get excited you start
you start taking the the nicotine gum
and you chew it like for two bit and you
throw it out the window
like it i would love to figure out a way
for it to be able to like set it up in
your car and you can do it like a gas is
eight bucks a gallon so maybe not but
when gas goes down we'll figure out a
way for you to drive around
and and do it from the car because that
would be badass
what do you got planned when are you
coming down
whenever you i i was thinking about i
want to come down
maybe
in july or even even this month whenever
you i love coming down
i want i don't want to get a place enjoy
your friends by the way were some cool
[__] people when i came down the
neighborhood people oh they still talk
about you oh i'm sure they do
oh hey they both could tell them like
boy he was high and then he asked for
the bagel and [__] and
tell them about tell these [__]
what those staten island bagels look
like oh well first of all we we i was on
i don't know 200 ish milligrams
and i think you just didn't want me to
drive home
because like we were sitting in your in
your basement watching tv for a bit like
we're going to someone's house like all
right i don't know where i'm going we
get there beautiful house there's so
many people there there's food which i
[__] i devoured a slice of pizza but
then they had these brown i think it was
i think their daughter was going or
their
children were going through a communion
so they had
they bought the bagel store it looked
like they and it didn't come in a
plastic bag they had like a
like a two grocery store bags full of
bagels they gave you i don't know if you
asked for they offered you one but i was
so shy and and um
high that i got too nervous to ask for
one but i was i must have just been
staring at your bagel just like
salivating because like would you want
one and i think i ate that bagel in
three bites
it was
oh a nice toasted bagel with cream i
don't even remember if it was toasted
with cream cheese
that was that was amazing you know what
i can't stop thinking about the shrimp
parmesan that we had at your daughter's
uh party just the shrimp with the cheese
on it the way it was bread i've never i
loved it
we didn't even know
what they wanted to stop thinking about
a mistake
and they gave us the right wrong [__]
thing they were like [__] bait like
baseballs
and i the fried shrimp is probably one
of my fav favorite things in the world
and i oh that was the one thing i was
like there's too many nice people here
we should have taken edibles for this
because i would have eaten you would
have had any leftovers if i if i had had
oh my god everything was good and then
my mom would god push thank you you got
pastrami for my mom on the way back oh
that pickles pairing they don't [__] her
dog they even make a [__]
cheeseburger
that you'll sit there and go how do jews
make such a [__] good cheeseburger
they they're tremendous over there the
pickle's herring
you know
they don't [__] around i went in there
with in fact rich voss is coming on
thursday to go to the pickle [__]
herring oh yeah yeah because that's it's
and you know we were in jersey they got
great jewish food everywhere but there's
something about the pickled herring
brother they know how to do it right
that [__] crinkle cut fries
they got steak fries in that
[__] you know what i
i the the food around here is okay it's
not bad
but
for you know there's nothing
that my happy place
is great food on a comfortable seat
watching tv that's all i want that maybe
i'm high a little bit i don't really
need much in life that's what i
that's why that's my happiness
and there's something about new jersey
that
i would be 800 pounds like it's just
everything's good
everything is nearby you don't have to
drive an hour like we went to pick up
the food for your
and we went to eight places and it took
us six minutes
it was it's just
if you like to eat
new jersey's the place to be i know that
should be there's commercials up here
for i don't know what i don't know i
don't want to say it but whatever county
you're in they have commercials up here
on the on the six o'clock news because
apparently it's good for businesses they
should put commercials that say if you
if you're a fat [__] like lee
who wants to joey move to new jersey
because i don't and by the way mike
the the donuts that he brought when
steve and i were there that are filled
with some sort of amish it could be
amish come i don't know what it is
it's so god those donuts are the best if
you haven't tried an amish donut
turn off this podcast and go get an
amish donut there i i got them i in
sarasota i went to an amish buffet and i
had about seven of them
because oh
they got amish in sarasota they got two
they have so many amish people there
they have two amish restaurants they're
dutchmen and yoders that's how
i know everything about oh and they have
buffets and it's like eight dollars and
the women walk around with the little
things on their head and they're very
sweet and that they've never seen anyone
like me eat the food because i might
have lost weight but i still can eat i i
i can't eat normally i can i'll tell you
really
well you need to
i don't know you've taken so many
edibles you don't even have munchies
anymore
i don't know what happened uh every once
in a while i get tremendous munchies off
those abx's i mean when you eat
i ate 1600 milligrams the other day and
i hadn't eaten them in like three or
four days five days i don't know
i ate a bologna sandwich oh nice mustard
and cheese mustard and cheese i ate two
italian ices the other night i had
guys i ate so many sunflower seeds that
one
i had splinters in my [__] because i
ate them with the shell on
first one i'm still good guys guys i'm
still good i still i mean i'm hooked on
cherries now
so my wife gets me these great new
jersey cherries it comes in a bag and
before i go to sleep i eat a [__] as
many cherries as i can
she's been getting me peaches lately
fruit but
the [__] abx is the only destroyed me
and i ate so much fruit in fact if you
go on my little refrigerator this fruit
i ate so much fruit yeah and i'm like i
still need something
so i just saw a bag of those what are
those seeds that you use for baseball
that you yeah sunflower seeds yeah you
spit them out and [__] dog i was so hot
i was eating the shell
oh my god when i woke up the next day
the shells were on my teeth and they
were like gooey it felt like a cavity it
was disgusting
i had to brush my teeth eight times but
the worst was when i went to [__]
and i opened up the vault and also
the first neck came out was like
splinters it was like
and then i tried to wipe my ass on my
eye
because i had all those bits breaking in
my ass forget it never again i'll do
that [__] dude those two hundreds are
danger i i took it i took it on a day
where i hadn't really eaten much and i
got so high and ate so much i wasn't
sick but i
this has only happened a few times in my
life i ate so much that there was
literally just not enough room i got out
of my girlfriend's bed walked into the
bathroom just puked but like didn't make
it i wasn't sick it just there was
nothing left i came out and i told her
and she said i'll go make you toast i'll
go get you a ginger ale
there was a piece of cake of of the
entenmann's
loaf cake that yellow whatever that
and i hadn't and
in the five minutes she was gone she
came back and i was i had just puked i
had just puked and i was finishing
those those abx's will turn something on
to me
but i mean
i couldn't stop i just i won't stop
that's why i don't do them every night
anymore because
you just took 1600 1600
atlantic city and i haven't because i i
brought a big bag to ac and i gave some
away to some of the savages but i didn't
take any i couldn't take a chance on
eating when going up on stage there was
no way i couldn't even remember the
material i had the 10 minutes
i forgot material friday night and i
smoked a joint you know with uh tommy we
smoked a
rainbow ruts and saturday i only smoked
a half a blunt that joe had
before i went on stage i was not gonna
be old school i wanted to feel
everything i wanted to make sure
this is what i want to do so yeah that's
that's what we got when you're more
comfortable and you're back in the swing
of things that's when i'm that's what
i'll know is when you're taking 200
before you go on stage
oh my god i can't
i'll never forget just all those nights
you taking all that [__] you like i have
nothing to say you go up there for an
hour and people are falling out of their
chairs with their face grabbing their
faces because their cheeks hurt
it's that's right i need a little i do
need a little bit more marijuana
in my life before i go on stage we'll
leave it at that
i do need a little bit more marijuana
before i go on stage i just wanted to
come i didn't want to be the same old
same old joey i just wanted to try
something different but
listen you
you can't teach an old dog new tricks
i gotta go just get high and get on
stage with three guys
yeah you know what just call me and i'll
tell you all my new ideas and i'll just
piss you off oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god no i can't go through that
[__]
i love you you [__] love you too buddy
yeah i'll get a weekend for you to come
down we'll get mike's i don't know
mike's got a couple things going on
so okay
mike works on saturday sometime so i'll
make sure we're now yeah i can come down
i work i work remotely i can i'll come
down i'll drive thursday night i'll be i
get off early on fridays i'll be there
you'll you'll give me edibles and i'll
be on zoom meetings just not making
sense telling them ideas how great would
that be to just do a zoom adam and look
at
somebody couple minutes and just just
[__] fall over like boom and they're
like hello hello so what do you want me
to tell the podcast host
tell them edible you [__]
i love you stay tuned we'll talk later
of course buddy have a great day thank
you for being on today my friend
anytime you want joey the the the app
amp app call these [__] all right
download the amp app um i'll look i i
think i have an email with it from
somewhere i think you do have a code if
you don't we'll get you one but
just get the amp app and get ready for
the joey diaz show and what about the
lisa and the least i had comedy shows
explosion and [__] that's made black
[__] suckers
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack hit it mike
love you buddy
all right you bad [__] we want
to try it differently this week so we
weren't right from [__] zoom i might
put on a camera twice anyway
the joint is brought to you this week by
factor listen if you can't stand the
heat
stay the hell out of the kitchen i can't
cook that's why a factory works for a
guy like me i spend less time in the
kitchen it gives me more time to go
outside and jump up and down this summer
fact is fresh i mean fresh
never frozen prepared meals are so
delicious you wouldn't believe they're
actually good for you these guys know
what they're doing over at factor all
right with 30 meals a week to pick from
you'll never be bored each meal arrives
prepared pre-prepared and ready to eat
in two minutes that's faster than
ordering that shitty pizza you're
ordering so do me a favor
go on
go.facto75.com right now
look at what they have to offer vegan
and veggie meals low calorie options
cold pressed juices smoothies energy
bites extra protein and veggie sides
i mean listen the menu is tremendous
from the smothered pork chops to the
garlic braised beef you know how to make
garlic braised beef no you don't this is
why it's great so go right now go to dot
factor 75 dot com
slash joey 120 i'm gonna get you 120 off
your first order that's 120 off your
first order you can't refuse this so go
to dot factor 75
go right now
preston joey 120 and i'm getting you 120
off all right healthy eating made easy
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion
when it comes to cbd nobody's as good as
the lion how do you know because i'm an
old man
and every week i got a new bump and a
new bruise and whatever and whether i
wrap the cream on it or i go in the bath
with the kinesiology
tape afterward i got the back ball
listen cbd lion is there from you from a
to z so do yourself a favor go to
cbdline.com right now
read the third party lab results that
there's something you want just pressing
code joey and with that dip
top magoo
i love you i want to thank lee i want to
thank mike i want to thank all you
[__] i want to thank draftkings
i want to thank factor and i also want
to thank
liquid iv for having our back it's been
a great week and we'll see you
[__] next monday
tip top [__] magoo
[Music]
hmm
you